i am not their therapist i am not their
psychiatrist i'm not their mother their
father
i am the person who's supposed to solve
their problem gets the point and i'll
solve your problem then hopefully they
put a period to the end of their legal
dispute and move on with their lives
that's my job okay your story
i'm waiting and i think that the viewing
public enjoys seeing
fast efficient
most of the time right
because i think that most of the time
the decisions that we make may not be
popular with both sides that's not
what's supposed to happen it's not a
popularity context but most of the time
the decisions are right do you
understand yeah that's ridiculous that's
your own ego what you see is what you
get i was commenting to someone that
when i was a sitting judge and i was a
sitting judge for about 15 years
people used to say to me judy hold it
down
don't get so excited you're going to get
in trouble you're not going to be
reappointed so i was constantly
challenged to keep it down
now they pay me for doing exactly what i
was trying to repress for 15 years i
said it before and i maintained the same
thing
when she was on the bench i called her
the joan rivers of the judicial world
man she shoots from the hip she takes no
stuff no prisoners and you know she's
not only witty but she has that mother
sense you know that that common sense
that people like to hear did you build a
rec room it's going to be built this
spring
don't you watch me often enough to know
that what you're doing now is not a
smart thing to do my training was in the
family court in new york city
and unfortunately with all the people
that we have in new york city we have a
lot of people who have problems
and because they do family court judges
are called upon to hear 40 or 50 cases a
day
that is in a seven hour day where we're
making
vitally important decisions about
vitally important family matters
in three to five minutes so you have to
be able to
cut to the chase get to the point and
keep your fingers crossed that your
common sense and visceral reaction to
things
are right is this your first time in los
angeles you bet having a good time
not right now
i think that
there is a certain generic quality to
problems
that transcend
where you live
in the country irrespective of your
socioeconomic position
the people that come here the problems
that they present are really problems
that they've allowed to invade
a particular period of their lives
sometimes people have been involved in
this dispute for a year or two or more
to them
it's
it detracts from the quality of their
lives because they are consumed with it
they can't get on with having a good
time because they're constantly thinking
that somebody has pulled a wool over
their eyes and they want to get it
resolved that's what we do
[Music]
you